a lot of girls who are promiscuous
because when I went to school there was
like there were girls who did that but
you could like identify it was like this
one over here this one over here they
had a reputation and a bad one and all
the guys like knew who they were could
we could we Define promiscuous because
that sleeps around okay what is so then
we go into like what is sleep surround I
would say 90 by 1950 standards 90 of
women are promiscuous they're like you
slept with more than two people you
[ __ ] so what I mean is sex that that's
not within the context of an actual
relationship multiple sex partners at
once in in terms of like you're dating
multiple guys you're sleeping with them
it's not an exclusive relationship
that's what I Define as promiscuous yeah
um I'm trying to think in high school
yeah there would be
I only I only had a couple
thing I don't want to say names that's
gonna just ruin everybody's life
Marianne you know who you are actually
they don't know their last names Bethany
waited till she was married there's
um you're already telling me it's not
prevalent though because you're having a
hard time well I'm thinking well no I'm
again it depends oh my gosh this one
girl I'm thinking of yeah but let's see
what I'm saying you're able to say like
this one girl now it's like we I put
panels up here and it's girl after girl
left oh I don't know my body counts
around 30 oh I don't know 15. oh it's
constant it's everywhere so I'm trying
to think like what happened between 20
30 years ago and now that made women
feel like this was a sign of empowerment
I would say the more crazy stuff was
like college like that was when like in
high school yeah I would say like the
crazy stories that I heard were more in
like college so but why do you think
it's viewed as empowering oh my gosh I
don't know that's it they're not on the
vice panel you saw it
I was like y'all just want to sleep
around with no consequences the feminist
said yeah yeah
and we're going to talk about by the way
I'm covering I just I decide I want to
say one more thing yeah I just feel like
everything in life is your own fault
that's how I feel that's how like that's
personal responsibility yeah everything
in your life is your own fault so yeah
and the the panel that Pearl's talking
about we're gonna talk about that I'm
actually gonna audience I'm gonna cover
that full panel for you you're gonna see
more Pearl in that battle on Monday oh
yeah but essentially like what was that
experience because it's a channel you
show up it's supposed to be feminist
anti-feminist was it edited tell me
about it oh it was so edited oh let's
let's talk about the libs on that panel
so first there's only two real
conservatives let's be honest you can't
you can't be you can't be Pro BLM and
like super conservative so they give us
four only it was really just me and
Sydney against the world shout out
Sydney and and it was actually six hours
we were there total so I don't know how
much we filmed I guess like three four
hours we were filming so maybe like hour
post hour before I don't know and that's
cut down to what an hour it was cut down
one 45 minutes oh yeah you can tell that
it's deeply they edit it out these girls
these oh one there's a guy guy Girl Eli
on the panel biological male trans woman
I guess I didn't know any of this before
because I'm just not in the conservative
space are you familiar yes Eli has some
allegations the allegations out against
it Sydney on the panel goes we're
talking about me too this is the
funniest part they edited out and she
goes that's funny
um that's funny that you say that Eli
considering the allegations that are out
against you with the kids like it was
like selling kids drugs and something
with minors I don't know I don't know
what happened I don't know it's true and
untrue so they took that out of course I
knew as soon as she said it I was like
they're gonna edit that they also took
out the girl in the front she was an
absolute I'm not gonna say it but you
know what I'm thinking I know 20 talking
about was like over she had this whole
freak out that they just like took out
what was it about do you remember we
filmed this in October oh I just
remember she was like very rude like
they took out so many parts of the
Liberals just acting insane like they
still looked in the same I promise you
it was 10 times worse my favorite is the
part where you're talking and they start
to like
psychoanalyze you like oh how did you
get this way and then the insults came
why do you hate women you're like I am a
woman and they're like you could have
internalized massage me I'm like oh here
we go that's that's fairy start they're
like trying to be your therapist and I'm
like this is why therapy messes women up
today did you enjoy doing it though oh I
had so much fun I love put me on another
panel I'm ready I'm ready to go I'll do
it again see I don't like I would love
to do with something like that live but
coming from like news where I know what
happens in the editing process I don't
trust any of them see I really don't
when I go into something okay this is
always my goal I want to be I want to be
so likable that even if you edit me the
worst way you still like me and you hate
it that's always my goal you came off
very sweet and very like like you were
just asking questions like what are the
barriers you know like you're just
asking what are you and that's good
though she's like it's like I have legs
and I'm like when talking about men
versus women y'all gonna see this you're
gonna lose your minds I want to ask you
about the labels that you get I'm sure
things get thrown at you like I covered
drew a follow here a lot I don't know
how much you know about her but the Pick
Me label oh yeah so do you I'm guessing
you get called you know a woman hate or
a pick me what do you think about that
oh well okay first of all I was like
what the hell is a pick me and so then
there it's like basically you say things
so men will pick you yeah but I'm like I
just say my thoughts I clearly am not
that filtered you know what I mean like
I clearly like sometimes I should say
less
I saw you yesterday on the show and
you're like the whales came for me and
I'm like she's talking about fat people
yeah yeah yeah sometimes my manager's
like yeah yeah so first of all second of
all I'm like pygmy that's the insult
that you want to get married yeah I want
to get married like but don't you think
it's interesting that they label like
men can't criticize modern women because
they'll be labeled misogynists women
can't criticize modern women because
they'll be labeled pick me so nobody can
criticize these women isn't that
convenient yeah and then they'll go to
the personal attacks like well why
aren't you why are you single and I'm
like that's what I'm saying truer is it
not true I'll be like Rebecca seven
abortions is a lot I don't know what
you're doing I mean a girl had seven her
name's not actually Rebecca seven
abortions wow seven and I'm like that's
a lot that is madness and it's like is
that true or is it untrue or should we
encourage it to get to ten should we
encourage it to get to ten
yeah what do you think is the biggest
mistake that young girls are making
today
oh um well I mean I think I think your
virginity is very valuable and I feel
like it's like giving giving that to
some like just a way you know yeah
that's what I would say sleeping around
yeah and just like promiscuity I would
say now you have one thing that's
interesting about you is you're very
open about your family like you always
will reference your dad and you'll say
on the show like my dad's in the one
percent the top do you get heat for that
do people say oh to write you off as
privilege from the start or yeah that's
why I don't try to hide it because it's
like they're gonna find out anyway you
know no um my dad is like the best
person my dad is so nice like literally
he helps everyone and he's so like I'll
call him crying and he's like stop it
so is he that masculine guy that you're
like it does does your relationship with
your dad or like your family Dynamic did
that inform how you feel about male
female Dynamics in any way or does that
play a role
yeah of course of course it does like
thinking because I would say my dad is
like not red pill like he doesn't know
what the hell I mean he's been a little
bit red pill just because because of the
contest no because of me I'll be like
Dad you won't believe the stat I found
out today I love it I love it but yeah I
mean I really appreciated being grown up
with like two parents in the home and
especially the more I talk to people
that did it because it's like really sad
when I hear about their holidays and
stuff like there's so many people that
my mom would kill me if I didn't go home
for Christmas and then like I'm in
England and there's like other athletes
and they're like I don't know we're not
doing anything for Christmas I'm like
you're not doing anything for Christmas
yeah my mom would would strangle me so
what do you want like if you were to
look at your life you know because the
other criticism that as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible